of course the first place we have to
visit is the beach right yes mate this
is prostitute the main city beach of
alicante and in the summer it is packed
[Music]
whoo all these steps so we made it to
the old town right yes this is the casco
antigua also known as santa cruz which
is one of the more picturesque parts of
alicante city
[Music]
all right after walking through the old
town we made it to the water this is the
esplanade or the main part of the
harbour side of aligante
we're going up to the castillo santa
barbara which is probably the best spot
to watch the sunset yeah and as you can
tell
it's on a little hill
off we go
[Music]
um
[Music]
what a beautiful sunset right what's on
now uh we're gonna go try some tapas
and of course
[Music]
alicante is like typical for seafood and
so this tapas restaurant you have this
little tiny thing you eat it it's worth
90 cents get a beer with it and that's
it
so basically you stack it up
and then they just count
the tablets and then you get a bill
like 90 cents each
[Music]
so our little tapas tour here in
alicante continues with the next spot
[Music]
delicious
all right and that is it from alicante
our last tapas place it's good my
bellies are filled you got something to
drink